[Musique]
bonjour madame guerra je m'excuse je me
suis installé mais je voudrais vous
demander quelque chose vous n'avez pas
fini encore nous interroger bonjour vous
avez à me dire asseyez vous voilà je
voulais vous demander si par hasard
l'autre jour n'est pas oublié de me dire
quelque chose
j'allais oublier un détail sur
l'importance
oh non plus non je crois pas madame je
vous connaissais depuis longtemps tous
les droits
oui nous sommes des cannas de travail et
avec guérin ça se passe comment
pour moi qui reste une brute c'est très
mal conduit avec monique passe pas mes
affaires
j'en avais gros sur le coeur alors je
peux pas m'empêcher de me confier à des
amis ouais vous voyez les guérin c'est
le genre de type qui n'a pas pu
s'habituer à la vie civile quoi mon avis
est dangereux
je crois toujours au barrou y trouvez ça
normal vous un type qui arrête pas de
parler à sa femme du maréchal de lattre
franchement et même sa photo là ça vous
a pas étonné qu'ils commettent se
veulent alors ça nan c'est d'arriver un
jour ou l'autre ils auraient pu
assassiner savez je le connais je
connais par coeur il faut j'avais peur
de rentrer à la maison et si je rentrais
c'était bien cause des enfants va vous
n'avez rien oublié de me dire
je remercie
là
[Musique]
tourcoing
enfin bon
c'est très bien qu'ils pouvaient rester
dix un présent ouvre vieux buzz viral
quand on sera à biarritz le viera
et elle
qu'est ce qu'on en fera quand on sera
bien
soit
tu sais pour les enfants cet accroc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]